[Música]
economía en directo américa de france 24
conmigo lista como siempre en el estudio
daniel hablando daniela ya si nos vamos
acercando a su tan esperado fin de
semana por si es mitad del hércules
mitad de semana nada ni el fondo
monetario internacional redujo sus
proyecciones de crecimiento pero que
dicen en américa latina o de américa
latina' mejor dicho hola raúl pues
latinoamérica y el caribe parecen estar
resistiendo al golpe de la guerra en lo
que a producto interno bruto se refiere
al menos eso lo dice este organismo que
subió tímidamente su previsión de
crecimiento para 2022 al 25 por ciento
frente al 2,4 por ciento anterior y esto
debido a que varias economías de la
región son exportadores de materias
primas y podrían beneficiarse del
aumento de precios también prevé que el
déficit fiscal de los países se
estabilice frente a los altos niveles
que habían la pandemia sin embargo el
fondo monetario internacional alertó que
el principal desafío ahora es controlar
la inflación y es que raúl mientras que
en perú la gente protesta porque
comienza a sentir el desespero de no
tener cómo llevar un plato de comida a
su mesa en otras naciones como argentina
en que los precios ya eran bastante
altos la situación no ha hecho más que
agravarse
ya en algunos países hemos visto a
personas protestar cuando ven que el
precio de los alimentos o de los
artículos básicos aumenta muy
rápidamente el aumento de los precios de
la energía y los alimentos va a causar
dificultades a varias personas
especialmente en los hogares y países de
bajos recursos entonces aquí lo que
recomendamos es que las autoridades
fiscales intenten usar medidas
específicas para intentar apoyar a las
poblaciones vulnerables
danny y seguimos de nuestra región de
américa latina y en el caribe porque hay
desabastecimiento en cuba y por ello las
autoridades pusieron entonces un control
de ventas no sí señor el gobierno local
de la habana solamente de la capital
anunció que a partir del próximo jueves
los ciudadanos de esta ciudad sólo
podrán comprar en las tiendas estatales
de los municipios en donde residen ahora
lo explicamos esto es como una manera de
hacerle frente a la falta de
disponibilidad de varios productos
esenciales como los pañales de los que
ya hay desabastecimiento en todo el país
o inclusive la carne de cerdo y el
azúcar cuya producción ahora es
insuficiente para un país que además
importa el 60 el 70% inclusive de los
alimentos que consume así funciona
entonces la medida todos los productos
que ofrezcan las cadenas estatales
caribe y cemex serán controlados y
regulados es decir serán descontados de
la libreta de abastecimiento que tienen
los ciudadanos en la habana y esta
restricción no aplica para las tiendas
que venden en divisas aunque no es tan
fácil acceder a las divisas en este país
es claro danny y se agita el pulso entre
disney y la gobernación de florida que
está pasando cuál es la polémica mire
usted qué historia tan interesante raúl
la empresa y el gobernador republicano
ron de santes se enfrascaron en una
disputa en torno a la nueva y muy
polémica ley que los críticos han
denominado no digas gay y es que esta
norma prohíbe la instrucción sobre
orientación sexual e identidad de género
a los niños desde el jardín hasta tercer
grado pues disney se mostró en
desacuerdo y también presionado por sus
empleados que dicen que la ley vulnera
los derechos de la población lgbt dijo
que retiraría toda financiación política
al estado ahora como respuesta a esta
postura el gobernador de santis pidió a
los legisladores locales que deroguen
una ley que le permite a disney hace
medio siglo raúl operar las 11.000
hectáreas en las que están ubicados sus
parques temáticos como un distrito
autónomo y auto gobernado escuchemos
estoy anunciando hoy que ampliaremos la
convocatoria de lo que los legisladores
van a considerar esta semana
entonces si consideraran el mapa del
congreso como está previsto pero también
la terminación de todos los distritos
especiales que se promulgaron en florida
antes de 1968 y eso incluye el distrito
de mejoramiento de reedy creek vamos a
ver entonces qué va a pasar en el ciudad
esto es muy grande si no llegan a ser
raúl pero por supuesto imagínese usted
daniela cifra el día mire los 40 mil
millones de dólares que perdió en apenas
un día netflix en su capitalización
bursátil es decir su valor en bolsa y es
que la acción en wall street se desplomó
en más del 26 por ciento el martes
después de revelar resultados
decepcionantes para el primer trimestre
y le voy a hacer un resumen sus ingresos
subieron pero perdió 200.000
suscriptores por primera vez en más de
una década en lugar de ganar los 25
millones que había previsto
solamente en rusia perdió 700 mil y
espera perder otros 2 millones a nivel
global en el segundo trimestre ahora
cierro con este dato la empresa dijo que
el desplome se debe al uso compartido de
contraseñas y a la competencia pues
asegura que tiene más de 200 millones de
suscriptores pero que 100 millones
utilizan el servicio sin pagar es una
localidad de ciudadanía de lo que
hablamos aquí también está estas
contraseñas compartidas y también por
supuesto demasiadas competencia todos
los días casi que sacan una nueva
plataforma de ser mentira y entre ellas
así es darle muchísimas gracias entonces
por toda la información de economía nos
vemos más adelante